continue de parler de la situation
sanitaire en france avec en direct dans
ce gîte et frédéric à thenay médecin
directeur du service des urgences de
l'hôpital avicenne ap-hp de bobigny
bonjour frédéric admet merci de répondre
à nos questions vous êtes directeur donc
d'un service d'urgence est ce que vous
contestez constaté un afflux de patients
important touché par le corona virus
dont le terme afflux n'est pas n'est pas
le long terme ce que l'on constate est
ce que l'on avait prévu c'est une route
d'épidémie avec si les une augmentation
progressive mais constante du nombre de
patients qui viennent aux urgences
ils ont admis en réanimation ou si vous
voulez une augmentation du nombre
d'appels au samu une augmentation qui
est modéré mais qui est constante depuis
deux trois semaines vous donner un
exemple j'accueillais un patient par
jour qu'ovide aux urgences de l'hôpital
actuellement je suis à quatre ou cinq
facile par chine la grande majorité des
patients beaucoup moins grave que lors
de la première vague
ce sont des patients jeunes qui n'ont
pas beaucoup de critères de réanimation
et donc l'augmentation du nombre de
patients en réanimation elle aussi
augmenté mais ciblé ce n'est pas une
vague c'est une augmentation continue
avec une pente qui est somme toute assez
faibles on peut pas utiliser le terme
d'affluence le lot mesure cette mesure
il se propage de plus en plus dans la
population générale mais son impact dans
les hôpitaux est encore modérée mais on
peut pas nier qu'il augmente mais ce
n'est pas sous les 1 un afflux ou un
débordement et jusqu'où est ce qu'il
peut augmenter justement est ce que vous
craignez une surcharge en réanimation
par à court terme on l'a bien compris
mais à moyen voire long terme pour cet
automne cet hiver qu'elle suit parce que
cette progression constante comme vous
le dites va perdurer en gros est ce que
vous êtes prêts dans les milieux
spitalier comme l'a dit récemment le
premier ministre jean castex
alors je n'ai pas de boule de cristal
mais ce que ce que je peux dire est ce
dont on est sûr c'est que lors de la
première vague on a été submergé c'est à
dire que on sûr on est arrivé on était
face à un mur de patients qui nous est
arrivé d'un seul coup avec elle le temps
doublement c'est-à-dire l'otan pour
lequel on avait deux fois plus de
patients est de l'ordre de 2 3 jours
actuellement il est de l'ordre de plus
de quinze jours donc si vous voulez on a
le temps de voir
alors jusqu'où ça va aller mais ça je ne
sais pas mais ce qu'on a l'impression de
nous mais ça c'est qu'on s'inscrit dans
la durée c'est à dire que ce pic
épidémique sera probablement plus faible
en cinétique par rapport à la première
vague mais sûrement et très probablement
beaucoup plus long donc on s'inscrit sur
plusieurs mois probablement à moins
qu'un vaccin arrive rapidement un vaccin
efficace qui sera effectivement un coup
d'arrêt brutal à l'épidémie mais là on
s'est inscrit dans la durée
alors est ce qu'on est prêt pour
l'instant n'est pas parce qu'on n'est
pas énormément impactés nous avons des
plans de montée en puissance de nos lits
de réanimation de nos espaces aux
d'urgence pour accueillir plus de
patients locaux vides mais je vous dis
si ça augmente avec un temps doublement
de de plus de 15 jours on vraiment
cinétique qui nous permet de nous
préparer à très progressivement autre
chose aussi important à savoir c'est
qu'avant les patients qui venaient en
réanimation ou qui était hospitalisé ces
journées beaucoup plus longtemps que les
patients actuellement téléphona turn
over beaucoup plus rapide en réanimation
et non en hospitalisation que lors de la
première vague en réanimation les
patients restaient 20 jours 30 jours
ventilé actuellement on est à 8 10 jours
de ventilation de deux fois moins
longtemps ce qui veut dire que les lits
vont se libérer deux fois plus vite et
est ce que l'augmentation de ces
chiffres laissent selon vous présager de
futures confinement a évoqué avec rennes
qui a déjà un plan qui est prêt et
éventuellement un confinement locales ou
partiel selon ouest france
je pense que leur confinement généralisé
est une très mauvaise idée car les
conséquences économiques et donc
sanitaire parce qu'on on oppose souvent
l'économie aux sanitaires en fait les
deux sont intimement liés
l'économie se dégrade le salutaire la
santé de la population se dégrade et on
le voit très bien aujourd'hui avec
toutes les pathologies non qu'ovide qui
ont aidé prise en charge avec retard mal
clients ça en charge à cause du
confinement si la paupérisation de
complaisons entraîne forcément un
dégradation de son état de santé il
serait faux de mettre en balance
l'économie la santé les si l'économie se
dégrade la santé se dégrade au que le
confinement
c'est aussi un impact sur la santé c'est
peut-être efficace pour freiner le but
ça va pas l'arrêter mais c'est aussi un
très mauvais indicateur sur l'état santé
le général de la population donc je
pense qu'il faut respecter les mesures
barrière notamment chez les sujets les
plus fragiles les patients âgés les
patients à risque ça c'est essentiel
pour nous protéger
l'hôpital est protégé évidemment les
patients mais le confinement ou leur
confinement généralisée je pense qu'il
est même pas envisageable
vous parlez des mesures barrières parmi
elles il ya évidemment le port du masque
la justice qui retoque le port du masque
obligatoire à lyon et à strasbourg
dans en extérieur évidemment quid des
autres villes selon vous quelle est
votre position par rapport à cela
pour écouter j'ai toujours été très
sceptique sur des mesures coercitives
moi je pense beaucoup à des mesures
plutôt pédagogique a essayé de
responsabiliser la population et
notamment les patients à risque parce
que c'est ça le vrai impact d'une
épidémie c'est les patients à risques
qui vont de faire la mortalité et la
morbidité sa dérive et comment les
protéger les patients à risque parce que
le port du masque c'est se protéger les
autres avant de se protéger soi surtout
oui mais écoutez qui se protègent bien
parce que ce que l'on voit actuellement
c'est que on voit surtout des jeunes des
personnes qui ne sont pas à risque
s'infecter et si vous voulez le fait
qu'on n'ait pas beaucoup de patients en
réanimation et on aura moins de 500 sur
toute la france elle c'est de l'évasion
à risques ne sont pas énormément affecté
actuellement je dis bien actuellement
parce recrudescence de cette épidémie
tout se passe comme si le message était
bien passé par là chez les personnes
âgées les personnes qui ont des
pathologies chroniques
tout se passe comme si se protège
beaucoup mieux puisqu'on voit souvent à
la télé des rave parties d'aider des
jeunes qui effectivement ne respectent
pas ces mesures barrières et simple
là est le vrai danger de l'été cette
transmission secondaire
deux de ces jeunes de ces personnes
n'ont à risque vers les personnes à
risque et actuellement ce que l'on
observe dans l'épidémiologie des
patients pour voir arriver dans nos
services c'est plutôt des jeunes plutôt
des patients qu'ils sont pas en reste
donc j'ai l'impression que le message
est bien passé justement chez sept
patients à risque et je ne pense plus à
la vertu de responsabiliser les la
population que de les infantiliser alors
déjà que si parce qu'ils auront une
amende
donc je suis les relents actuellement
des messages réguliers vers les
personnes les personnes à risque pour
leur rappeler les mesures barrières
dernière question dernière question
rapidement par rapport à la stratégie
face heures au coronavirus on a du mal
un peu à comprendre
est-ce qu'il faut que le cirque le virus
circule
le gouvernement qui dit il faut vivre
avec est-ce qu'il faut que le virus
circule pour atteindre une immunité
collective par exemple dans ce cas
pourquoi toutes ces mesures ou est ce
que il faut qu'on attende qu'il
disparaisse de lui-même ou qu'un vaccin
soit disponible c'est quoi la stratégie
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
le mesure les mesures barrières ne vont
pas arrêter le virus les mesures
barrières simplement freine le virus
dont toute la problématique pour nous
médecins c'est de contrôler cette
épidémie c'est à dire de maîtriser la
vitesse à laquelle la virus se propage
dans la population on n'arrivera pas il
ya aucune mesure qui arrêtera le virus
c'est soit le vaccin sûr comme vous
l'avez rappelé l'immunité collective
donc le virus va circuler
on a des moyens de contrôler sa vitesse
de propagation la façon de contrôler sa
vitesse de propagation
ce sont les mesures barrières le port du
masque la distanciation le tracé et
enfin la quatrième chose l'immunité
collective donc limité collective elle
progresse elle elle est là est évaluée à
10% elle doit un peu plus importants
auxquels athènes et des chiffres autour
50 60 % pour arrêter le virus donc ce
qui faut nous c'est resté dans un style
une situation contrôler c'est à dire que
la cinétique et la vitesse de
propagation de ce virus en population
générale n'impacte pas de manière
significative nos structures
hospitalières elle conçoit pas dans une
situation comme on l'a été d'un première
vague de débordements on est ainsi on
nous met des barrières n'arrêteront
jamais le virus merci frédéric cadet
d'avoir répondu à une question je
rappelle que vous êtes directeur des
services d urgence à l'hôpital avicenne
de bobigny